i just actually got off the phone with  why juanita lives right here  behind us in a valley and then ashley  lives right there i got to take actually  in the morning to get her stitches out  after her catastrophic accident yeah she  it was a pretty bad one right  very serious she could have died and  she's surviving she's very courageous  she can't get out of bed but um  wow we call this is like a it was  compound  too wonky to call us a  it's peaceful valley yeah i love that  y'all live together  i think that's amazing your family's so  close it's not always peaceful though  well it's a lot of estrogen naomi yep  i'm still here  just waiting for you to subscribe if you  don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever  help